Buonasera
c'è un grande assente nel dibattito di
oggi su quello che è la scienza la
tecnologia e l'innovazione
questo assente è il dubbio
la società odierna la società basata
sulla conoscenza abbiamo preso il dubbio
e l'abbiamo messo da una parte rilegato
lontano abbiamo trasformato il confronto
in un approccio fideistico e il dialogo
scientifico e non confronto tra tifosi
della Ternana con tutti i tifosi del
Perugia
ecco
Io vorrei
Diciamo in questo Ok ma tu hai tolto il
dubbio cosa ci hai messo ci abbiamo
messo in mito
l'aspetto mitico l'aspetto mitologico
Ecco io vorrei spronare a dire
attenzione riportiamo il dubbio la
domanda anche in pertinente anche
fastidiosa anche irritante come
strumento metodologico per confronto tra
idee
ora nella necessità di avere certezze
noi abbiamo personificato il dubbio
abbiamo personificato scusava nella
personificata in mito facciamo un
esempio Allora mi date 10 secondi di
tempo ognuno di voi pensi intensamente
alla figura di uno scienziato
immaginatevi davanti a voi la figura di
uno scienziato provatelo a vederlo
bene Quanti di voi hanno pensato questo
adesso ci hanno pensato questo
c'è pensato vi invito Guardate una cosa
Guardate non assomiglia un po' questo
ci assomiglia eh
pensate hanno delle caratteristiche
identiche sono tutti di due personaggi
simpatici simpatici un po' eccentrici un
po' strani tutti e due studiano da soli
un problema astruso studiano tutti e due
il tempo
e tutti e due risolvono il problema da
soli in autonomia su questo problema
astruso lontano
signori questa figura non esiste
lo scienziato Oggi è un manager o una
manager lo scienziato oggi ci gestisce
risorse umane materiali e finanziari e
rendiconta queste sue
su queste sue attività si muovono
all'interno di un mondo di regole
chiamiamolo progetti di rilevante
interesse Nazionale chiamiamolo PNR
e non può essere libri muoversi Tanto è
vero che molte volte i suoi obiettivi
non possono non sono stabiliti in
quell'ambito ma sono stabiliti
esternamente
Guardate questo signore qua uno dei più
grandi italiani Giulio Natta Premio
Nobel per la chimica oggi il suo studi
per le macromolecole non potrebbero
partecipare ai progetti di rilevante
interesse nazionale con la tua le regole
Ecco noi abbiamo tolto il dubbio abbiamo
messo la certezza
sapete quante volte avete sentito dire
se finanziate questa ricerca questa
malattia scomparirà
questa ricerca questo problema
scomparirà
la ricerca non dà certezza risultati se
no non è ricerca e trasferimento cosa
importantissima ma non è ricerca la
ricerca non dà certezza
abbiamo tolto il dubbio ci abbiamo messo
una cosa
che si chiama algoritmo
l'algoritmo mi risolve
l'algoritmo prevede
un signore qualche tempo fa una
sessantina di anni fa Lorenz misi in
evidenza un fenomeno in realtà già
studiato prima lo mise in evidenza che
fenomeni determinati cioè regolati dalle
leggi deterministiche ricorsivi
lui era un fisico della dell'atmosfera
quindi faceva previsioni del tempo uno
dei primi
Dicevo bene se tu conosci un sistema e
conosci le regole del sistema
non sai però come sistema evolve perché
il sistema può evolve verso una
situazione caotica di imprevedibilità
questo secondo me è una mazzata enorme
sapete quanto è ammazzato
Allora noi prevediamo l'aumento di
temperatura 20 30 50 anni giusto due tre
gradi poi si discute
bene Qualche tempo fa poco tempo fa c'è
stato l'evento più drammatico
atmosferico negli ultimi 60 anni 60 anni
ha colpito due province italiane la
provincia di Pesaro Urbino e di Ancona
ha fatto 12 morti non è stato previsto
da nessuno
Voi capite che prende coscienza della
non prevedibilità di un evento anche se
conosco le leggi che sono alla base
dell'evento è una bella trasformazione
Ok ma però diciamo sì
però noi siamo alla ricerca di soluzioni
nuove soluzioni tecnologie pulite
molte volte diciamo tecnologie bene
la tecnologia pulita mito protostorico
perché la tecnologia pulita cioè da
questa spada magica è la soluzione che
risolve in maniera definitiva un
problema Quale quello che fa vulcano per
Zeus a cui dalle armi per combattere i
Titani nella loro scalata all'Olimpo
quello che fa Kotor arvasi per bar
mitose Mitico o quello che fanno i nani
per Odino la Lancia e lo scudo o per
toro il martello Cioè è chiaro che sono
miti i protostoici quindi storici in
ambito mitologico che riguardano la
metallurgia quindi il sistema però il
concetto è ti do un qualche cosa che mi
risolve definitivamente il problema e
dove viene creato questo qualche cosa
in un altro scuro
da potenze telluriche molte volte
deformi i luoghi non accessibili esseri
umani
cioè qualche cosa che è una conoscenza
nascosta in cui il risultato viene
utilizzato voi ce l'avete La spada
magica Io ce n'è una
Quanti di voi possono vivere senza
questo
sapete cosa c'è dentro questo
ci siamo mai chiesti se il mio selfie ad
alta definizione Quanta energia richiede
ci siamo mai chiesti che quella energia
è fornita da batterie mai pensate che
quelle batterie richiedono per esempio
totalio e che questi provocano di
sconvolgimenti sociali in altre parti
del mondo
non è un mito della spada magica questo
cioè noi utilizziamo qualche cosa è
indispensabile ma non abbiamo coscienza
di come prodotto non abbiamo coscienza
di niente
quando parliamo di energia pulita
Tolgo Tolgo tocco argomenti delicati
quindi me ne rendo conto eh quando
parliamo di energia politica pulita è un
ossimoro
perché è un simbolo
perché è un principio della fisica ci
dice che qualunque processo di
produzione e trasformazione trasporto di
energia viene con rendimento minore di 1
quindi ai produci dello sporco tu non
scegli la pulito tu Scegli quello sporco
vuoi
poi possiamo dire sì però se noi
investiamo i ricerca e tecnologia
abbiamo un miglioramento della società
Cioè a livello sociale menta siete
sicuri come facciamo un salto indietro
li pensiamo un attimo
alla prima rivoluzione industriale
un signore watt
fa inizia a lavorare Alla fine del
Settecento inizia gli studi sulle
trasformazioni di energia e sulla
produzione di vapore
e le sue conoscenze le sue ricerche le
sue invenzioni Sono alla base della
prima rivoluzione industriale
che non ci sarebbe stata sebate non
avesse incontrato Bolton
un imprenditore
Chi ha trasformato quelle ricerche
quelle innovazioni in strumenti
disponibili alla società
Cioè se il sistema sociale non ha il
corpo il suo la struttura a percepire
queste innovazioni non può portare a un
Progresso sociale
Allora vi chiedo e mi chiedo perché
tanti laureati italiani se ne vanno
all'estero
perché tanti dottorati di ricerca
trovano difficoltà e trovare posto di
lavoro perché troppo anziani avendo tre
anni di laureati avendo studiato cioè
attenzione la struttura sociale è in
grado ovviamente di recepire
effettivamente quello che l'innovazione
quindi noi investiamoci investi Ma poi
questo tuo percorso se manca tutto
riuscissi a fare l'aspetto di scoperta
quindi di licenza o lo spettro di
trasformazione tecnologica si trasforma
in un Progresso sociale ce l'hai gli
strumenti
non è mica consequenziale
i Midi sono pericolosi perché il mito
pericoloso perché mito ha una dote il
rischio
e rischio può essere pericoloso
tolgo sempre argomenti delicati so che
qualche suscettibilità ci può essere no
non è stata forse il mito della spada
magica dell'energia pulita che nel 19889
fece dire un ministro della loro governo
togliamo tutti i fondi per la ricerca e
mettiamoli sulla fusione fredda che si
rivelò per una grossa bufala ma il mito
era la spada magica
non è stato forse mito della spada
magica cioè della soluzione pulita
che le fece dire ministro Nel 2020
L'Italia non ha bisogno di opere
infrastrutturali perché basta mandare un
file e produrlo con le tecniche di
costruzione uditiva
un attimo mi occupo di costruzione
uditiva di stampa 3D dal 1995
un chilo di polvere Metallica costa
dalle 20 alle 40 volte di un chilo di
materiale massivo signora lei
spenderebbe dalle 20 40 volte per la sua
lavatrice
lei spenderebbe 40 volte in più presso
l'automobile
un conto è la capacità tecnologica un
conto è sul trasferimento in una
avanzamento sociale
non è stato forse ignito forse qualcuno
se lo ricorderà qua della paura della
mancata innovazione che fece dire alla
fine del 1999 se non cambiate tutti i
vostri sistemi operativi non ci sarà più
acqua potabile non ci sarà più
distribuzione Ve lo ricordate
Simpaticissimo micro mito del Banco del
millennio
ecco
il mito
si porta in dot il rischio il dubbio
dovrebbe perlomeno prevenire un po' di
rischio quello che invito noi anche come
come Scienziato come ricercatore
impariamo a mettere il dubbio
all'interno anche delle nostre più forti
certezze Vi ringrazio per l'attenzione
[Applauso]